let's talk about this hypothetical class
of twenty people two excellent people
that you think have potential to have
careers and the eighteen that don't do
you think those eighteen people want to
hear the truth knowing that they can be
it's malleable they can you know the
sort of you can mold them too but do
they really want to hear it and talk
about this growth mindset versus what's
the other side of that coin which is to
fix my exam okay and so how do you know
you're experiencing a student that has
the fixed mindset offer and they don't
want to hear it perfect perfect perfect
question that is such a smart question
so the fixed mindset
first of all believes that if you want
to be a writer you either have this
talent or you don't so then it's you are
constantly have this voice in your head
that says do I have what it takes do I
have the talent am I wasting my time am
I going to get a career or is it never
going to happen for me
that constant cheer based fear-based
chatter is that fixed mindset and
because of that the fixed mindset and
you have such a smart question it
desires an outcome so if I have a script
and I go hey will you guys read my
script and just give me your feedback
I'll know what you think there's the
fixed mindset in the growth mindset and
they're both there I don't think it's
one or the other I think they both exist
it's just sort of a ratio are you 90
percent growth mindset and 10 percent
fixed or the budget when I give you guys
a script occurs tell me what you think
my sticks mindset wants an outcome it
wants you to to say well now I know why
you had a career now I know why you
teach others this is maybe the best
script I've ever read I am I'm literally
in awe to be in the same room with you I
didn't know human being to write this
this well this is this was the most
amazing script ever like that's what my
fixed mindset wants to hear and when it
doesn't hear it it's going to throw a
temper tantrum and at that point it has
two choices and only two choices which
is what's wrong with you guys or what's
wrong with me so you always hear writers
out there say yeah my manager said that
the characters weren't strong enough you
know I got changed managed
I mean he doesn't know what he's talking
about or they'll say yeah the manager
said the characters weren't good enough
I don't I don't know why I know good at
characters there's something wrong with
you or something wrong with me
the only choice is that it has the
growth mindset does not crave or desire
an outcome it desires the truth so the
growth mindset wants to know what did
you honestly think and why did you think
it and let's say that there are parts of
my script that you really loved and
there was a section of the script that
you just didn't care for why and not in
a defensive way and not in an attacking
way but why because it's like a
detective it's like hmm what plays in my
head is amazing it's not amazing for you
I want to know why where is that
disconnect maybe there is a piece of
information there context that I knew
that you didn't I didn't get out well
enough and if I could just rewrite it so
that becomes more viscerally clear to
people maybe you'll then have the
experience in law maybe that section I
like it for very personal reasons but it
actually disconnects from this there's a
whole million reasons but if I and maybe
maybe the reason you didn't love my
script the honest truth is the
characters just weren't compelling
enough for you they felt kind of flat
they felt kinda like they all spoke the
same way that's not now a rewrite which
is the mistake most people make that is
okay I'm not yet strong enough at
characters or the story the characters
great but it kind of wandered around and
it just it just didn't seem like it had
a forward thrust and maybe I'm just not
good at that forward thrust great that
growth the fifth mindset of course is
freaking out but the growth mindset is
celebrating because it's like okay now I
know what I can do moving forward to get
better as a writer and I got to figure
out how do I train myself to get better
at forward thrust or so or better at
characters and so if you follow a growth
mindset when you get feedback if you
love my script top to bottom and I know
the process that I use to create it and
I can replicate
that process that is great news for me
if you didn't love my script top to
bottom and I can talk to you in the
right way to figure out why you didn't
wear the disconnects were and I could
realize where I have a weakness where I
need to get better at a skill set where
I need to create a new talent or get
better at a talent and it can figure out
how to do it that's amazing so the
growth mindset is not looking for an
outcome it's looking for the truth so
your question was really profound those
18 people did they want to know that
they are in 18 people if you ask them
they all say yes the reality is if you
were to tell them and I never did I
never that was for right or wrong
reasons that was a line I would never
cross I would never tell someone if I
thought they had what it took or dinner
I just didn't want it because I felt
like that's just my opinion what is my
opinion worth at the end of the day and
I don't want to inflict that on someone
positively or negatively so I don't know
I'm not saying this wisdom of the right
decision but as a teacher to this day if
someone says do you think I have what it
takes right well first of all say go
read mind set because that's a fixed
mindset question but even if I actually
have an opinion I'll never tell someone
anyway but if I if someone were to tell
those people they would say I want to
know the truth and that is true for
their growth mindset but their fixed
mindset does not want to know the truth
it wants an answer it wants a specific
answer it won't say yes or the fixed
mindset would be okay with I don't think
you have what it takes but I don't think
it will take that long for you to get
there the fixed mindsets like oh all
right I'll settle for that but anything
beyond that and then the fixed mindsets
like what do you know or yeah I don't
you know so and the reality is what I've
learned is that we are always both six
mindset and growth mindset and if you
really do the work you can feel you know
kind of the ratios and in fact like
people often ask me why I teach and
there's a lot of answers but
one of the main reasons that I do this
is as a writer I had a very unhealthy
relationship with my writing it was
really torturous experience because as a
writer I was about as sticks mindset as
you could be as a teacher I'm about as
growth mindset as you can be so for some
reason teaching is that one space in my
life where it is just so easy to be
egoless and growth lines up and you know
for other people maybe that's religion
or parenting or whatever
for me it's teaching not sure why but it
is and I didn't even know about mindset
at the time that's something I learned
later on a brilliant student said hey
you should read this book I think and it
was like oh my god where's has been my
whole life and but yeah so for me
teaching I'm sorry writing had all these
demons and and anxiety and fears and it
was just as I was was a very angry
person and it was either what the f is
wrong with my agent or this executive
and this and just or what is wrong with
me and that was my only two choices and
as a teacher it allows me to live in a
growth mindset place and to be a much
it's very healing for me and it's just I
get so much out of that and then I
really love working with writers and
really helping them find and stay in
that growth mindset because that is so
important to a writer
you